well latinos overwhelmingly voted for
president joe biden and vice president
kamala harris
polls also revealed that support was
critical for the democrat win
in nevada hector mejia explains how our
local immigrant community is reacting
to the new administration
i feel a sense of relief a sense of
excitement for evelyn alvarado the 2020
presidential election was
primarily the reason why she became a
u.s citizen
in november she voted for the first time
supporting change
in the white house the community was
scared policies that
were implemented a sentiment of
racial injustice and division in our
country
the biden campaign promised sweeping
immigration reform
an issue alvarado is familiar with we
fled el salvador because of violence
the immigrant home foundation nevada's
largest latino nonprofit
says there was a lot of fear among
latinos during the trump administration
erica castro with the group progressive
leadership alliance says
a biden administration means renewed
protections for her
she's a daca recipient it means
finally have having some protection from
deportation
being undocumented still having my
family my parents that are undocumented
i know how much fear the trump
administration created just to play my
household
before the election latinos ranked the
economy
healthcare and covid19 as the top three
issues according to the pew research
center
a lot of latinos specifically immigrants
work on the strip are as housekeepers as
cooks just part of the service industry
and we've seen a lot of them being hurt
because of this pandemic
hector mejia reporting 8 news now